sprack we don't know why you aren't more
popular Fleur you were selected as the
Triwizard champion of your entire school
that means you're brave and really smart
but you were so hated in the books
especially by Ginny and Hermione even
your mother-in-law was pretty terrible
to you
it's really not fair at all you are
definitely one of the most underrated
characters in all of Harry Potter Fleur
Delacour
isn't the only Austen character that
gets overlooked keep watching to find
out which character is one of the
bravest slytherins ever here are 10
Harry Potter characters that are
completely underrated mr. manage
creature creature the house elf isn't
exactly likable when we first meet him
he's angry that Sirius is the only black
left because he thinks he's a blood
traitor and creature really hates
muggle-borns but we soon learned there's
a lot more to this elf he really loved
Regulus black who died trying to defeat
Voldemort and he is proud of Harry for
fighting the war he leads all the
Hogwarts elves into battle against the
Death Eaters tongues if there's one
character that we wish we saw more of
it's Nymphadora Tonks but she hates her
first name so just call her tongues
don't call me Nymphadora Tonks was a
Hufflepuff and the daughter of and
Romita black and ted Tonks she was goofy
and could change her appearance at will
she's the only metamorphic as we meet in
the books
Tonks was also really brave she was an
armor she married lupin and they had a
baby tonk swim to fight in the Battle of
Hogwarts
even though teddy was just a couple of
weeks old unfortunately she didn't
survive rita skeeter rita skeeter as a
character we'd love to hate she's such a
great minor villain Rita is extremely
powerful as a journalist she has a
problem with not telling the whole truth
but everyone who reached The Daily
Prophet reads her stories she's also a
very talented witch
one of the rebel hairy scratch that last
she's an unregistered animagus which
allows her to spy on conversations she
does end up helping Harry in order of
the Phoenix by writing a factual nice
article about him Kingsley Shacklebolt
the AH returns minister for magic
doesn't get nearly enough screen time in
the movies but if you read the books you
know he is awesome he's described as
being really cool he even has an earring
he worked undercover at the muggle Prime
Minister's office he was a super brave
member of the order of the Phoenix he
was also a great R who stayed working at
the ministry during the war he is the
one who warned everyone that the Death
Eaters were coming to bill and fleurs
wedding kingsley becomes Minister for
magic after the war Remus Lupin he might
be a werewolf but Remus Lupin is one of
the kindest characters in Harry Potter
he is definitely the best defense
against the dark arts professor that
Hogwarts had ever seen he is one of the
masterminds behind the marauders map he
is best friends with James Potter and
Sirius Black he cared deeply for Harry
and he went undercover with evil
werewolf's for the war-whoop and died
with his wife Tonks at the Battle of
Hogwarts
we are still sad about that so now I'll
say goodbye I feel sure we'll meet again
sometime Madame Pomfrey it can't be easy
being the only healer at a magical
school can you imagine the types of
things poppy Pomfrey has seen at
Hogwarts kids and magic are a recipe for
disaster but she does a great job fixing
up Harry and everyone else Madame
Pomfrey is also the only person tending
to everyone's injuries at the Battle of
Hogwarts
did you know Dumbledore hired her to
help Remus Lupin when he was a young
werewolf she's one cool lady Dean Thomas
Harry Potter's door mate Dean Thomas was
a great friend to Harry
he supported Harry many time
when other people turned their backs on
him he even defended Harry about
Voldemort being back when his best
friend Seamus didn't believe it
Dean's biological father was killed by
Death Eaters in the first war Dean has
to go on the run in Deathly Hallows
because he can't prove that he's a
half-blood he is kidnapped and held
prisoner by Malfoy Manor and he is saved
by Dobby and fights at the Battle of
Hogwarts Minerva McGonagall
Professor McGonagall is one of the
toughest witches around when she went to
Hogwarts she was a hat stall which is
super rare
this means the sorting hat took a really
long time deciding whether to put her in
Raven fall or Gryffindor McGonigle is a
great teacher and she defends her
students no matter what she even stands
up to unbridgeable things I would like
to see she really cares for all of her
students as if they were her own kids
flora delacour flora delacour is the
Triwizard champion from BOE baton school
she is half Vela which makes her
extremely beautiful but she's a lot more
than her looks she is very clever and
does a great job competing in the
tournament she is brave which is why the
Goblet of Fire chose her she is a loving
big sister flora deals with a lot of
hate from the Weasleys but she doesn't
deserve it at all she and Bill Weasley
get married in the seventh book Narcissa
Malfoy
Draco's mother is a complicated
character she never becomes a Death
Eater even though her husband and son do
she loves Draco more than anything and
she takes huge risks to save him she
makes Snape take the unbreakable vow
forcing him to protect Draco and killed
Dumbledore if Draco cans otherwise
Voldemort's would kill Draco she also
lies straight to Baltimore it's face
about Harry being dead when she finds
out that Draco is alive
she is one brave Slytherin who is your
favorite underrated Harry Potter
character tell us in the comments thanks
for tuning in give this video a big
thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe
to the things
[Music]